[Music]
Rick and Morty follows the lives of a
crazy grandpa scientist his grandson and
the rest of the family
this totally inappropriate show has a
huge fan base and even more jokes that
sometimes go way over our heads are you
ready let's get swifty don't forget to
subscribe to our channel and like this
video today we'll show you ten
inappropriate jokes in Rick and Morty
you might have missed I know this isn't
the time we all know Rick is a genius
scientist with certain problems that
make him completely reckless and
hilarious on the job of course every
smart person has their downsides and
Rick just can't control his drinking
habits this often results in having some
of the most hilarious and inappropriate
scenes like this one this moment
happened in season two episode 8 called
interdimensional cable - tempting fate
coincidentally it's also the very first
Rick and Morty episode to be rated
mature at the beginning of the episode
Beth and Rick have a conversation while
trying to take care of Jerry Beth
suddenly asks Rick why he would keep
mutant bacteria in a pint of Cherry
Garcia and he casually replies that the
second freezer drawer is his and he can
do whatever he wants with this imagine
having a casual conversation like this
all while you're trying to save the life
of a patient it seems a bit weird
doesn't it it's definitely a comical
scene but does it fit in the hospital
setting well this definitely isn't the
raunchiest joke in the series it's still
inappropriate considering the job Rick
has we've heard stories of doctors
discussing strangely bizarre things
during an operation before and this Rick
and Morty scene just confirms that it's
kind of inappropriate Szechuan sauce
joke a lot of Rick and Morty jokes have
been turned into memes and are popular
worldwide we bet you've heard of this
one even if you don't watch this show
well this is not a totally inappropriate
moment in the show we find it
unbelievably hilarious Adult Swim
featured a 24-hour stream of Rick and
Morty season three premiere episode
which gave a shout-out to the one and
only McDonald's in the episode Rick
finally revealed why he roamed around
through alternate realities and you
won't believe his answer he said it was
so that he could get another taste of
the Szechuan dipping sauce McDonald's
carried as a part of a tie-in promotion
with the Disney movie Mulan well that's
definitely not inappropriate we know
that Rick himself is known for never
really
telling the truth and could very well be
lying so whether or not he really meant
it this caused a stir among the fans who
really wanted to see it happen even
McDonald's got in on the joke and fans
are also bringing in theories that the
2018 release of Mulan would be the
perfect time to bring out the Szechuan
sauce once again whether or not this was
intentional it was definitely one of the
hilarious moments what a good way to
make McDonald's be aware of the show
Wall Street we've heard a lot of wall
street jokes over the years but Rick and
Morty took it to a completely different
level this quote belongs to season two's
episode called Morty night run and of
course Rick is the one who said it Morty
asked him what kind of business he does
in a garage and admitted that it sounds
a little bit Shady Rick then
sarcastically replies that nothing shady
would ever happen in a fully furnished
office and refers to wall street
he asks Morty if he knows what those
guys do in their fancy bedrooms and then
of course in a true rick style refers to
dipping certain things in certain
illegal substances and wiping them all
over each other
he then points out that he goes around
and does this type of business in public
because he's not the shady one we won't
tell you what things and substances Rick
was referring to but we're pretty sure
you'll be able to figure it out Wall
Street doesn't seem to mind because the
Wall Street Journal gave the show a
shout out and even wrote about the
show's second season we'd bet they
changed their minds about the show if
they actually saw the second episode of
season 2 or maybe this just proves that
even Wall Street has a good sense of
humor Morty's glip glops the Rick and
Morty show is no stranger to some of the
weirdest innuendos and inappropriate
jokes most of them are of course started
by grandpa Rick who seems to have
absolutely no filter and says whatever
is on his mind
Rick is the type of person that can
easily get away by saying the most
bizarre things because he masks it into
something else if you watch the show
you've heard of glip glops their turf
lore Kean's a small species of green
aliens that make a few appearances
throughout the show of course Rick has
an interesting term for them and it's
even more interesting as he explains it
he calls it glip glops and says that
it's a combination of some of the most
derogatory words having a baby and then
being raised by other words you should
never say he then proceeds to address
the turf lore qian's as his glip glops
all while morty looks very much
concerned to be fair if we had a grandpa
that's as crazy as Rick we'd probably be
concerned
- we won't tell you what Rick actually
means by calling for Fleur Qian's glip
glops but we're sure you can imagine it
was pretty inappropriate even for a show
like Rick and Morty we're not sure
what's weirder seeing little green
aliens on this show or Rick's
inappropriate jokes
Rick's burps Rick and Morty doesn't hold
back when it comes to presenting
characters with no filter and Grandpa
Rick definitely fits that description
Rick's burps are nothing new but there's
actually more meaning to the way this
genius scientist burps yes we're not
kidding
his belching might just mean more than a
regular gas passing his burps are now a
huge part of Rick's persona and they
even go as far as being included in many
inappropriate jokes we've heard on this
show we have to admit they make us feel
uncomfortable every single time but
after we found why Rick continues to
belches words it made us appreciate them
a bit more we found a secret meaning
behind his burps that somehow makes them
even more hilarious trust us you'll
appreciate Rick's terrible manners when
you hear about this one have you ever
heard of a comedian called foster Brooks
this famous actor was best known for his
hilarious impressions of men under a
substance and his impression included
burping out words in the same way as
Rick sure you might think it's
completely disgusting but if there's
anyone that could pull off burps it's
probably Rick
well it turns out his burps aren't
really an original thing because foster
Brooks is tipsy persona made him a
pretty popular comedian we can imagine
Rick's belching might gross out quite a
few people but we hope you're able to
appreciate the hidden message behind
these burps
sniffles one of the probably most
bizarre scenes on this show happened in
the episode lawnmower dog and trust us
this is bizarre even for a show like
Rick and Morty the title of the episode
is a reference to the lawnmower man
which actually inspired this episode but
before we get on to the actual joke did
you notice that Rick mistakenly calls
the dog ruffles it might be his old age
don't forget that he is a crazy grandpa
after all but ruffles was also the name
of the dog in a project called dog world
which belongs to Justin roiland the
co-creator of the show we suppose we'll
never know whether this was
intentionally done or not but we do know
that the bedroom scene with snuffles was
actually intentional now this particular
scene has a very inappropriate joke that
easily gets over people's heads snuffles
changed his name to snowball and said
that snuffles was actually his slave
name
according to him snowball fits and
better since his fur is pretty and white
we will let you figure out why he
decided to change his name but we're
sure you'll be able to get to what
snuffles or should we say snowball is
referring to with his fur color it's
just one of those moments that's
definitely inappropriate and if there's
anyone that's able to get away with
inappropriate jokes like this it's Rick
and Morty
Ethan feels like a girl another quick
terrible joke happened in the episode
called anatomy park which is the third
episode of season one Rick and Morty is
no stranger to terrible and
inappropriate jokes but we wonder if you
were able to catch this one the first
time you watch the show the scene
focuses on Ethan summers boyfriend we're
not sure when the two became
romantically involved but they reveal
their relationship in this episode but
many fans haven't noticed that the scene
where he described he felt like a girl
has a much more inappropriate joke
Ethan describes how his older brother
took him fishing once in the bushes and
then ended up crying saying his brother
made him feel like a girl we won't go
into too much detail over what we think
actually happened to Ethan but it's safe
to say that the event wasn't nearly as
funny as it was traumatizing we're sure
you can figure out what exactly made
Ethan feel like a girl in this terribly
inappropriate joke that most people
actually miss the first time they
watched the episode the title of this
episode is of course a tribute to
Jurassic Park and you can actually find
several references to the iconic movie
throughout the episode their entire
culture is built around what this
slightly inappropriate joke did make us
giggle did you catch it in season 2
episode 8 we get a special little cameo
from Werner Herzog who plays the alien
in a wheelchair many fans have thought
this was actually an impression of the
famous voice actor but no Werner was
actually on the Rick and Morty show the
episode revolves around Jerry having to
decide if he wants to lose his manhood
to save the life of an alien leader
doesn't it sound like a typical Rick and
Morty plotline well the aliens seem to
have had enough of humanity and they
proceeded to tell Jerry how the human
world is still undeveloped Werner
continues with one of the most hilarious
Rick and Morty monologues ever even
though it might just be slightly
inappropriate he says that the entire
human culture is built around their
manhoods and well we kind of have to
agree with him the alien in the
wheelchair then proceeds to say he's
tired of manhood
humor and has been to parties where he
saw the most bizarre displays of this
culture Gerry of course the hero that he
is defends his own species saying humans
definitely understand genocide as they
do it sometimes to the entire joke
definitely saved the episode but Warner
did bring up a good point Morty and
summer did you ever catch this joke in
season one this is one of the most
hidden scenes that many have missed the
first time they've watched the series
Morty and summer have a very typical
brother and sister relationship they
fight they get upset and sometimes
they're best buds nothing out of the
ordinary right well do you remember the
episode where Rick and Morty visit mr.
goldenfold's dream morty gets visibly
freaked out when he notices a bunch of
bizarre and somewhat flirty aliens but
he's even more freaked when he spots his
own sister and mr. goldenfold's dream
world since mr. goldenfold is actually
Morty's maths teacher this is definitely
one of the most inappropriate jokes but
it gets even better after they returned
back to the real world summer goes up to
hug Morty and to no surprise morty gets
upset at the fact that he just saw his
sister with far fewer clothes on in the
dream world of his math teacher morty
slightly pushes her away and gives us a
very uncomfortable face which could
easily be missed if you don't pay
attention we feel you Morty we'd be
upset too it's definitely not a pleasant
sight get schwifty
get schwifty is an anthem to all Rick
and Morty superfans
but you have to admit that it's just a
little bit inappropriate of course the
show should never be watched by kids in
the first place though we're not sure
how we feel about the lyrics of this 1
minute long song that has over 7 million
YouTube views here's something you
probably didn't know about this joke of
a song get swifty was written by Justin
roiland the co-creator of the show and
he even makes a cameo appearance in the
song can you spot him in this picture
we'll give you a hint
justin has ginger hair in real life he
definitely knows how to get schwifty get
schwifty belongs to season 2 episode 5
where a giant head demands to see a hit
song performed and starts a religion
around it of course Rick being Rick
comes up with one of the most bizarre
and slightly inappropriate songs called
get schwifty the song in which Rick
proclaims that you got to get schwifty
also talks about taking off your clothes
and forgetting all about your bathroom
manners the song has since then got a
few popular remixes
is still a popular reference to the show
we love that Rick and Morty can
sometimes goof off like this and forget
that they're still on air we bet there
are plenty of more hidden jokes and
scenes to re-watch of this show so make
sure you comment below and tell us what
we've missed that's all for 10
inappropriate jokes in Rick and Morty
you might have missed for more videos
like this one check out 10 inappropriate
jokes in good luck charlie see you next
time
[Music]